Transcriptor: Hussein Ahmed
Revisor: Daniela Pardo
Levante la mano el que es feliz siempre.
Levante la mano el que es feliz
algunas veces.
Y levante la mano
el que no es feliz nunca.
Bueno, menos mal.
Menos mal que nadie levantó la mano.
Porque déjenme decirles que todos,
todos queremos ser felices.
Yo les voy a contar
un poquito de mi historia.
Porque este tema de la felicidad,
créanme que es bien complicado.
Cuando buscamos en Google “felicidad”
salen más de 500 millones de resultados.
Y yo les pregunto:
¿La felicidad...
...es una emoción?
Levante la mano el que crea
que la felicidad es una emoción.
Un sentimiento.
¿Qué será esto de la felicidad?
Porque definiciones hay miles.
Hedonistas, trascendencia, religiosas.
Yo les voy a contar
cuál fue este camino para yo ser feliz.
Para encontrar y vivir la vida
que yo me merecía y no la que me tocaba.
Una señora colombiana bien puestecita.
Elegante, bonita, con todo.
Todo lo que todos los seres humanos
piensan que es la felicidad.
Pero déjenme decirles que yo no era feliz.
Y no era feliz
porque no sabía qué era la felicidad
ni de qué dependía la felicidad.
Pensaba que la felicidad la iba a lograr
el día que me casara
y tuviera el hombre perfecto
que me hiciera los masajitos.
O el día que tuviera mi primera hija,
o el trabajo perfecto.
O mi primer carro,
un millón de dólares en el banco.
Y todas estas cosas que creemos
que nos hacen felices.
Pero yo no era feliz.
Un día, sentada con mis amigas,
hablando de la vida,
yo decía: “Dios mío,
yo no me puedo quejar.
Si yo tengo todo”.
A todas mis amigas y a todas las personas
con las que yo hablaba
les faltaba la mitad
de las cosas que yo tenía.
Entonces,
¿qué era la felicidad?
Algún día escuché que había
un profesor de Harvard.
Tal Ben-Shahar y yo, bien atrevida,
le escribí por Linkedin y le dije:
“Vea, Sr. Shahar
¿qué será esto de la felicidad?
Porque yo no soy feliz”.
Y el hombre me contesta:
“La felicidad es una ciencia
que se estudia
y se basa en la psicología positiva.
Y si usted quiere aprender
de la felicidad, vaya ya a Miami”.
Hay un congreso.
2017 fue un año para mí...
...de crisis.
Lo primero que hice fue irme para Uruguay
para un retiro a encontrarme conmigo misma
porque migo misma estaba como por allá.
Después entendí que migo misma
siempre estaba conmigo.
Pero yo no era amiga de migo misma.
El retiro.
Me voy para el WOHASU,
el primer congreso de la felicidad.
Era la primera que me sentaba
en la fila y la última que me iba.
Y entendí
que ahí era donde quería estar
el resto de mi vida.
¡Vaya!
Me encontré con muchos mitos.
El primero fue: la felicidad
es el éxito y el placer.
Y yo quiero que ustedes levanten la mano
si conocen a alguna persona muy exitosa,
con muchos millones y con mucho placer,
pero que no son felices.
Yo conozco.
Otro de los mitos: esta expectativa que
se nos genera ante las cosas que queremos.
Y yo quiero pedir una pizza.
Me imagino esa pizza deliciosa,
chicludita, con el queso que se estira
y cuando llega la pizza aplastada,
fría, horrorosa.
¿Qué pasa conmigo?
Mi imaginación defraudada.
Yo creía algo y eso no era.
Para eso empecé a estudiar
a Mihály Csíkszentmihályi,
un científico espectacular
que habla del fluir.
Este estado del ser humano
donde lo que hacemos nos apasiona.
Yo fluyo aquí,
fluyo hablando de felicidad.
Otro de los mitos es creer que
las personas felices no tenemos problemas.
Mi mamá me decía, y me dice hoy,
cuando me pongo brava,
así que me da un mal genio,
o digo una mala palabra:
“Niña, ¿y tú no eres la de la felicidad?
(Risas)
¿Y te pones brava?”
Pues sí, me pongo brava y me da rabia,
y pataleo, y grito, y lloro.
Porque me reconozco vulnerable.
Y el día que entendí
que podía ser vulnerable,
y agarrar y tener pataletas, y ser feliz,
ese día entendí que la felicidad
era un camino
que yo tenía que recorrer
todos los días con mis decisiones.
Y yo les pregunto.
¿De qué depende la felicidad?
¿Tu felicidad?
Yo sé de qué depende la mía.
Porque yo creía que mi felicidad dependía
de que yo me levantaba supercontenta
y llego a mi oficina y mi jefe
tiene una cara de trozo.
Ya se me acabó la felicidad.
O el marido que un día decide irse
con otra y ya se me acabó la felicidad.
¿De qué depende tu felicidad?
Ese es el primer paso.
Para esto les traigo
el estudio de Sonja Lyubomirski que dice
que el 50 % de la felicidad
depende de la genética.
Hoy empezamos a hablar de la epigenética.
Una ciencia que nos dice
que el ADN sí se modifica.
Pero bueno, eso será otra charla,
espero que me inviten.
El 10 % depende de
las grandes circunstancias.
Grandes cosas.
El millón de dólares, 90-60-90,
el marido perfecto.
Pero eso solo es el 10 %.
¿Y entonces qué nos queda?
Un 40 % de decisiones.
Decisiones que sí nos marcan la vida.
La primera es fundamental:
las personas que tienen fe
sí son más felices.
Cualquiera que sea tu fe, no importa.
Vivir en propósito.
Como dice Viktor Frankl en su libro,
El hombre en busca del sentido:
“Cuando encuentras tu propósito
la vida te pone los cómos,
te pone a las personas,
te pone las maneras de lograrlo.
Pero el propósito se vuelve una lucha
tan inalcanzable como la felicidad”.
Todos tenemos un propósito.
Consciente o inconsciente,
pero no sabemos que existe
porque se nos da fácil,
porque pensamos que el propósito
tiene que ser algo supermajestuoso.
El propósito está ahí.
Yo creo que desde antes de que nacemos.
El entorno... ay, ay, ay.
Esta parte es fundamental.
Las actitudes de la gente
también se contagian.
Lo bueno y lo malo.
Y hay estudios que muestran
que las cosas de las cinco personas
que tenemos más cercanas
también se nos pegan o con el entorno.
Tú decides con quién te juntas.
Tú decides con quién tienes tus hijos.
Tú decides con quién formas tu hogar.
Tú decides si tienes vitamigos
o te juntas con esas personas tóxicas
que en últimas te roban tu energía.
Es una decisión.
¡Comunidad!
Yo les digo a mis amigos
que yo me baño en todos los aguaceros.
A mí me encanta pertenecer.
Soy de la Policía Cívica,
soy de la Junta Acción Comunal,
me meto en el edificio,
soy del grupo de clubhouse,
tengo una plataforma,
hago esto, esto y esto.
Me encanta pertenecer.
Me encanta juntarme con personas
que tenemos sueños en común.
Porque ellos me van a ayudar,
como yo los voy a ayudar a ellos
a cumplir ese propósito.
Y aquí viene la parte más difícil.
La mente.
La imaginación.
A Teresa de Jesús
la llamaban la loca de la casa.
Y yo quiero que me digan,
¿cuántos de ustedes
se dejan dominar de la loca de la casa?
Porque esa loca de la casa siempre
está con pensamientos negativos.
Más de 60 mil pensamientos diarios
y más del 90 % negativos,
Llega uno y digo: “Ay, ¿qué pasó?”
Esta suposición que nos tiene ahí.
Pero si somos capaces de calmar la mente.
Somos capaces de calmar la emoción
y también vamos a poder calmar...
...la acción.
Cuando me certifiqué en la escuela
de Disney de servicio al cliente,
entendí que si no puedes cambiar
la mente y no puedes cambiar la emoción,
cambia la acción, porque esa acción
te va a hacer cambiar tu emoción
y te va a hacer cambiar tu pensamiento.
Ojo con la loca de la casa.
Porque nosotros somos el resultado
de nuestras decisiones.
Entonces ya sabemos
de qué depende la felicidad.
Ya sabemos qué es la felicidad
para nosotros.
Ahora, ¿qué nos robará la felicidad?
¿Qué serán estos hábitos que tenemos
que nos alejan de la felicidad?
Les voy a mostrar los míos.
Cada uno tiene los suyos.
El primero es la comparación.
Que mala costumbre tenemos de compararnos.
Oigan y siempre nos comparamos
con personas superestrellas.
A donde jamás en la vida vamos a llegar.
¿Por qué no nos comparamos con esa persona
que tiene menos bendiciones que nosotros?
Para que podamos apreciar y valorar
nuestras bendiciones.
El juicio, el juicio contigo misma.
Porque a veces podemos ser bien duros.
El control, ¡ay,ay, ay!
Esto sí que me costó trabajo,
porque mandona sí era.
Y no saben soltar el control
y aprender a decir:
“Prefiero ser feliz que tener la razón”.
Fue bien difícil.
La Organización Mundial de la Salud
nos hablaba de que en el 2020,
y eso que todavía no había pandemia,
íbamos a tener una de cada cuatro personas
sufriendo de ansiedad,
exceso de futuro, depresión,
exceso de pasado, estrés, exceso de ahora.
“Me dejaste en visto,
ahí está Chulitos,
¿por qué no me has contestado?”
“Ya, ¡apura!”
Por favor.
Identifiquen los ladrones de su felicidad.
Porque si somos capaces
de modificar esos hábitos,
vamos a poder cambiar nuestra vida.
Vamos a poder encontrar
ese entorno saludable.
Dejar la culpa.
No confundir la culpa
con la responsabilidad.
Excesos de pensamientos.
No dormir bien, no comer bien,
no descansar.
Y aquí los invito
a que nos descubramos en 4 pasos.
Identifica tus dragones,
qué te roba la felicidad.
Encuentra tu pasión y tu propósito.
¿Para qué estás aquí?
Descubre tus talentos y tus virtudes,
porque el 80 % de la gente,
cuando se vaya para allá arriba,
o cuando se vaya,
papá Dios, o quien sea, le va a decir:
“Oiga, yo le di a usted
el don de la comunicación”.
¿A mí?, ¿comunicación?, ¿yo?
El 80 % de la gente
no conoce sus dones.
Y por último, ¿quién te inspira?
¿Quién te inspira?
Porque te pueden inspirar para bien
y te pueden inspirar para mal.
¿Y cómo están inspirando tú
a las personas a tu alrededor?
Fundamental para ser feliz.
Cinco Inteligencias.
¿Cómo me relaciono con los demás?
¿Cómo me relaciono conmigo misma?
¿Cómo me hablo cuando estoy solita?
Inteligencia emocional.
¿Cómo voy a manejar mis emociones?
Porque cuando estamos bien,
a no, todo fluye.
Pero cuando tenemos una circunstancia,
ahí es donde tenemos que sacarla.
Inteligencia espiritual.
Estar bien a pesar de las circunstancias.
Y la existencial cuestiona,
cuestiona de todo el tiempo.
Todo comienza por ti.
Y aquí les regalo
la fórmula de la felicidad.
A de agradecimiento.
C de correctas decisiones
y no significa que no me equivoco.
Claro que me equivoco, pero aprendí
a ser responsable de mis decisiones.
Entorno saludable.
Ya hablamos de eso.
P de propósito.
T de tiempo para mí.
Tiempo para meditar, para orar,
para conectarme con mi alma.
Yo saco a pasear a mi perro
cinco veces al día.
La gente me dice: “El perro
te está sacando a pasear a ti”.
Y amor y servicio por los demás.
Porque el día que no hago un acto de amor
por algo, por alguien
yo tengo una fundación de mis perritos.
Al día siguiente tengo que hacer el doble.
Pero todo comienza por ti.
Aceptación y cambio.
La felicidad para mí es un estado del alma
y es como aprender a nadar.
Hay guías, hay maestros, hay manuales.
Hay que aprender a ser feliz y hay que
aprender a renunciar para ser feliz.
Y hay que escoger para ser feliz.
Y se logra practicando,
practicando y practicando.
Porque para mí,
la felicidad es un hábito.
No sigas buscando la felicidad
donde no la vas a encontrar.
Te invito a que la provoques.
Y para terminar, conoce,
dedícale tiempo a conocerte.
Ten buenos hábitos, actúa.
La disciplina y la estrategia
que tengas serán tus grandes aliados.
Haz más de lo que te hace bien.
Y haz menos de lo que te haga mal.
Y yo te pregunto,
tú que estás ahí:
¿Eres feliz?
Porque la felicidad se nota.
Gracias.